another day
another attack
and more deaths
a rocket hit this playground in
ukraine's second largest city kharkiv
killing two people as they sat on a
bench
all that remains is blood stains on the
ground and bread on the bench
we're at the site of a cluster bomb
attack from multiple launchers
these are the parts the clusters they
are forbidden by international law and
russia uses them illegally these are
against infantry and light armored
vehicles it was intentional to hit
residential area to impact civilians
there are no military objects around
here
one resident recalls the moment the
rocket hit
the city i was sitting by the entrance
then i went upstairs and then it hit if
i hadn't gone upstairs i wouldn't be
here right now they hit on the other
street the shell hit one after the other
a couple of hundred meters around the
corner they're cleaning up the damage of
another impact
now it's the familiar process of
boarding up windows
73 year old gregory koliakov says he's
had his russian-made larder for over 40
years it survived everything except the
russians
i heard the sound of the rocket and then
we heard another one and i said get down
i hit the ground but my friend was a
little slow and got wounded
this area has clearly been hit by
cluster munitions
and there seems to be no method to the
madness of what's been targeted it's a
residential area but also
there's damage to civilian
infrastructure
and in this bus depot every bus seems to
have some sort of shrapnel damage
barrage of strikes hit a large area
a child's playground multiple blocks of
apartments and buses at their depot
it's a surprise more weren't killed or
injured
back at the playground some are
traumatized
go on die
man and woman
die
he says why
what did they die for
i said
foreign